foreign
experimental photographer and I run a
vintage camera YouTube channel
today I'm going to walk you through the
restoration of a 60 year old's edexa
camera
edexa cameras are pretty rare to find
they were made in West Germany in the
60s and they have something really
special the viewfinder that lets you see
from the top what your photo will look
like
when I saw the camera on on the table at
the yard sale at first glance I saw that
the camera was really filthy really
dirty the skin cover was falling apart
the foam inside that protect the mirror
was totally dry and lastly there was a
razor blades in the middle of the review
finder so I was pretty surprised when I
opened the camera
foreign
first to have access to the razor blade
I need to remove the prism and now that
I have access to the focusing screen I
can remove the razor blade
next I remove the old flaking skin from
the outside of the camera
a camera skin is the faux leather that
covers the camera because of time and
sweat the laser starts to peel off or to
rot and so it's important to change it
next I replace the old dried foam with a
new set of foam that will protect the
mirror
on every film camera you have a little
strip of foam that will protect the
mirror most of the time with age the
foam dries and you need to replace it
I changed all my vintage cameras from
because most of the time when you buy
them you don't check and you realize
after that that your mirror just broke
once I remove the old skin of the camera
I have under it it's gluey disgusting
residue and if the skin fell long before
sometimes you have a lot of dirt and
areas that accumulated on the body of
the camera this residue of glue is
easily removed by using acetone so I'm
just using acetone and some tissue and
I'm rubbing the surface to remove any
trays of glue
then I remove the base plate of the
camera
I use the blower to remove any dirt from
the inside of the camera and so no
problem so I just cleaned the base plate
and put it back
to replace the black paint on the camera
body I use the black permanent marker
because it's almost impossible to remove
it so if you have sweaty palms or it's
raining on the camera it will not affect
the dominant marker
after that I cleaned the dials I'm using
a specific Q-tip with a really sharp
edge to remove the dirt inside the small
letters
I use also some rubbing alcohol to
dissolve the grease and the old dirt the
more you can get back the original color
of the letters the pattern of the camera
will look
next I'm cleaning the frame it's all
metal so just a toothbrush will do
perfectly and with the Rubina code I can
remove most of the grease and old dirt
to clean even further the camera body I
used an eraser that is really good for
removing the really fine particles on
the metal
after the frame is clean I need to clean
the mirror
on the surface of the mirror you can
find fungus
cleaning the mirror is pretty tricky you
can't clean a mirror with any kind of
tissue because it can make some marks on
the mirror so for this I used a really
soft Q-tip with rubbing alcohol
after that I open and clean inside the
prism because it's the part that is the
most dirty when you take apart the prism
you need to be careful to not drop
anything because just one chip in the
glass and your image will be less
interesting
inside the prism viewfinder you can see
a lot of grease and dirt the owner
before and maybe just kept it on the
table in the dust accumulated inside the
viewfinder and it was pretty disgusting
for that I just need to use dish soap
and water and it will remove most of the
grease on it
with the years and years and years of
dust tiling up on the lens and with a
little bit of Grease or someone smoking
it can create this kind of greasy
surface if I want my camera to last
longer I will store it just in a box or
in its office full case anywhere but
just not in open air
next I'm going to clean the focusing
screen
the focusing screen is one of the most
important parts of your camera because
it's where you will see your image form
and it will help you frame and focus
your final photo because the focusing
screen is All Glass I just used some
dish soap to clean it and because it's a
pretty robust glass I use the tool brush
because there is no real risk of leaving
any scratches on it
[Music]
foreign
I will apply a new skin on it this
specific skin comes from Hugo Studio
which is a company that creates
custom-made skins for people who wants
like me to restore vintage film cameras
the glue under the new skin is really
strong and if you put it on the wrong
spot it will be stuck in the wrong place
for this camera I wanted to use a
crocodile for leather I wanted to give
the camera a fancy look if you don't
care you can just add some gaffer tape
on it and it will work the same to
protect the camera but it will not look
as good
foreign
lastly I want to add my personal touch
on the camera so I add a custom made
orange dot on the rewinding lever
next I'm just touching up some of the
paint that is missing on the letters
for this camera at least I used umbral
enamel paint
[Music]
when I found the camera at the yam sale
I bought it for 10 euros and it was in
pretty bad shape but now that I fixed it
and gave it a new skin you could sell it
for between 200 to 300 Euros but for me
I will keep it in my collection because
I like it
foreign
[Music]
ER you can really see the world through
the lens of the radixa it makes some
beautiful photos and it's really magical
tool to create beautiful images